because you know there will be a
secret show out there somehow with
somebody somebody's gonna pop out there
just like cage did a few years ago um
and just like you know there was gonna
be that
possibility of the foo fighters um
there's gonna be somebody out there and
sure i
you know what if you give me a second
i will look through the schedule and
give you an idea as to who i think it
might be
um santa rate lifts a very good
possibility you know that's just a big
band to start taking out there
uh but i mean the ruham guys have an
event on friday evening they do they're
having emo night which you know could
could be some good dashboard bombs there
yeah
um there is a there is a quote unquote
secret show at the beer exchange i don't
know if you guys know about that um
oh you know i mean i wouldn't put it
past i wouldn't put it past jack anthony
off and going out to a plaza late friday
night and doing something
that'd be cool so we don't even know i
mean it you know it's very possible you
we wander out there and just stay out
there you know
if somebody's got a cachet of pbr i can
see
i may never see taco
taco's gonna sleep on him see him all
weekend i guess he'll sleep on a bed of
pbr
uh yeah or you know maybe in a dark room
tent somewhere oh man
i could see jude and the lion doing
something late saturday night in a in a
in a uh in a plaza i could see loop
daddy finding something to do on friday
night i mean yeah you're right there's
there's very good possibilities of
something popping up uh throughout the
festival out there